bang
what's up [ __ ] faces we are live with
another episode of punchline I am the
one and only Jason Tebow on Google Bulls
we've discussed I'm here with the newest
paid recognize you were past a while ago
earlier in the year but got your name on
the wall
yesterday congratulations to my good
friend and a hilarious comedian and big
sports fan
Lucas Errol everybody Lucas Tebow's oh
thank you now why are we starting so
late
one may ask hey last night was fun i i
got woke up set my alarm for 8:50 and
9:07 those are the two times that I had
set 8:50 turned off and I pretty much I
think I just threw my phone flush it
down the toilet when the first alarm
went off I wake up the second time and I
say to myself god I hope it's not after
10 a.m.
cuz then I'm gonna have to hustle to get
here at 11 it was 11:15
you got a missed call from Erin missed
call from you and so I apologized but
late but we're gonna make it happen and
we're making it happening now how cool
was it to get your name on the wall I
was feeling dude I don't know yet it was
you will it was amazing it was because I
got passed about 10 months ago yeah you
got pencil wild yeah and Adam when he
called me the one thing he said is like
you know I'm sorry we just put new names
up so you're gonna have to wait a lot so
it's gonna be about 10 more but I
promise you'll get it up there
and you never know with the store when
that's gonna like happen well you know
you do actually
Mitzi's birthday yeah yeah Mitzi's
birthday's last week so yeah I think
they could get a hold that schlip that
always does it you know he's got it's
always done in there ya know they have a
new guy now though is that a new guy
who's the new guy yes well that's why I
didn't show up on Missy's birthday this
bozo no no I mean everybody nobody was
here but Brenton told me Sunday nights
like by the way your name's one on the
wall tomorrow morning I'm like really
you know yeah so I think the fact I had
to wait 10 months kind of made it almost
more special but did did you forget
about it in those 10 months you're doing
spots you're getting regular spots
you're doing
you're doing the [ __ ] our late night
getting regular spots did that make you
go wouldn't it when Brennan Biddle come
sit - you did it make you go oh [ __ ]
I totally forgot I actually get my
[ __ ] name on the wall table yeah yeah
yeah and you know it just look like Brad
Williams got past like two days ago
yes yeah it's like right before they
right when they announced the guys is
gonna like oh we got the painter guy
hooked up well a bit better past a
couple of these people in passed him in
somebody else that's like a no-brainer
to pass Taylor Tomlinson it's just
someone else best Brian Simpson I know
and and Juran but there was another
person - Oh Ron Ron but there was
another like I kind of like a more
famous comic that doesn't really code
Pat nozzle yeah that's enough so Patton
Oswald them [ __ ] Brad Williams stay
private like oh and by the way write
their names - if you have a little more
white paint left oh that's my favorite
is when they pass like some big names
did they do it every year every year
Sarah Silverman got passed a few years
ago and I said this a few years ago oh
no [ __ ]
yeah but those are the people that like
didn't come through the system yeah so
to speak uni and I'm not there every day
there but they're just like famous and
they're like hey if you were to come by
and do spots David Spade will type your
name on the wall yeah Colin Quinn got
past - and I had no idea that right but
a lot of people the more famous ones you
never see there anyway no you know but
Patton Oswalt's been coming in and
that's it's been so bad because I was
Brad yeah but I grew up with Patton
Oswalt and like he's the only person
I've ever seen so I meant at the store
yeah I started a comedy there eight
years ago and how long have you been at
the store yeah I started comedy at the
store so 8 years old 8 years ago yeah
yeah I started a lot guy and then after
about a year I became a bartender but
pans the only guy I've ever seen who
just knew how to work the Oh r-right he
really if you ever watched him in there
he's he's a seasoned pro it took him no
time to like adjusted I wrote writer
write
the darkness of it whatever I think he's
just like perfect for it yeah yeah he's
like oh this is this
pretty much my family's Thanksgiving
dinner this is exactly how this always
goes for me yeah so pardon me I also
wanted to show up yesterday like you
know 9:10 a.m. and be like hey put me
here what time that I I'm hoping to get
my name on the dumpster
what time did what was that at I I think
he started a little bit after 11:00 took
a couple hours you were there Josh
Martin was there Josh wasn't there oh he
wasn't there Geron was there yeah
because I was I mean I think and that
seems to be a tradition that a lot of
people do is like you find out what time
they're actually painting your name on
the wall and you just show up and watch
this [ __ ] paint him on the wall
like don't misspell my [ __ ] don't fight
don't [ __ ] yeah no totally cuz I have
I have a name you must be a lot of
people misspelled do you yeah they spell
it with an H you are oh oh I could see
that I could see that yeah I'm first and
last name that is always misspelled oh
yeah you have to be there when you do
yeah yeah with a lawyer yeah um now
what's interesting about we yeah I think
you're the placement of your name is
awesome
but I don't know if you've thought about
this it is directly across straight
across from the bar that you bartend
that for so long and pretty much the
bane of your existence yeah your name is
literally my boss from the [ __ ]
definitely bane that's a good that's a
good that's a bad name
do you remember when Josh Martin had a
patio mic out there Josh more during the
day oh I do remember that oh yeah and I
was complaining about a bad seven I
actually did it oh yeah it was it was a
great mic yeah yeah Josh Martin had a
open mic just so people adore talking
about what he would do an open mic
outside at the patio a bar during the
day the Sun would still be up before
o'clock me after yeah so like the bar is
gonna open at 7:00 the club's gonna open
at 8:00 and from 5:00 to 7:00 there's
gonna be if you show up in any audience
and it was always people from the hotel
across the street or you know the across
the parking lot
that's who always with bodies members it
would be other comics but random people
that were just Australian they're always
Australian for some reason
that Lao ye yes a ton of jokes a Brenton
I was complaining about a bad set one
time the Brett and he's like at least
you've never bombed in front of your
name because his name is right by the
stage where they would have the mic Oh
uh-huh and in Brentwood worked the
phones and he come down and do a spa and
you know like eat [ __ ] right in front of
his own
that's hilarious yeah that's hilarious
that's perspective that is for a sec you
know I always think about that it's no
talking to run and congratulation to
everybody that got past or at least
their names on a wall no one's really
recently been past but I was talking to
Ron about it and I go dude that think
about that that is your headstone like
wherever you get buried or if you get
cremated or whatever that's just for
your few family members that you've that
outlived you yeah you know I mean no
one's gonna go to my grave in two you
know Northwest Indiana or wherever I
wind up being buried and that's pretty
good Barry I don't know in two months
but I'm what once I'm talking pain
paying it off but wherever you happen in
one of your hometown or wherever you
wind up getting me no one's gonna go
there and look at your name and wonder
but at the Comedy Store in a hundred
years
someone's gonna perhaps see your name
and then go oh I'm gonna Google that
person and see it and then see your
comedy in a weird way that is more
important of the headstone at least it
with your art then whatever rock that
they sizzle your [ __ ] name in and
bury your carcass underneath yeah
because no one's gonna go to that
[ __ ] place and google you or wonder
about your art or because now with the
internet that [ __ ] just lives forever
it just is out there so your name being
on that building is just an opportunity
for people to still look you up it's
still even even post mortem keeps you
relevant in a way I don't even care
about that I mean I just think that you
know my family would probably rather
visit my name at the Comedy Store when
I'm dead then go to some goddamn right
of course
podunk Iowa graveyard if you ever
thought about how you would kill
yourself every day yeah what are your
tie
my top ones what are your top ones I
mean mine are all violent yeah me too I
want to get put in Chains and then set
on fire and then before on top of a
really tall building that's overlooking
the sea and then before I Mike right
before I burn to death push me off of
the building and then let me fall into
the sea and drown that combines
everything that everyone's afraid of
burning to death drowning to death and
falling off of a big building I mean
which one is gonna kill you I mean it's
really you could say you pick him not to
fall the fall won't kill me the fire may
but drown I think the drowning will be
eventually what does it he met a great
tweet like a week or two ago about like
if you're gonna jump off and build it
anymore
yeah he's like if you're gonna jump off
a building like have a holy skateboard
so people think you're trying I guess
that is hilarious and then the other one
I thought was funny that I would want to
do which is the opposite of the one I
just mentioned I just want to get into a
put myself in a body bag and just zip it
shut and just wait like eventually
you're gonna starve to death or
something you'll just die a veteran you
hate yourself I mean I'm not a fan as
much as I am uh yeah you're right hey
what are yours
um I slit my wrists once oh yeah 18
minutes ago yeah not 18 um was it over a
girl no no it was more just frustration
uh-huh you know it was like high school
was ending and then you're like I don't
know what I'm gonna do yeah now yeah
might as well kill me I remember this
period really well because like I'd met
Ted Nugent the day before most people
try to select our wrist the day after
meeting Ted Nugent is really nice good
but we were going to New York for like a
little vacation the next day and it's
the worst pain I've ever had because
when you when you do something like that
you're you know they stitch it up but
they don't that's all they do and your
body just has to make a new
vain because I severed a vein Wow and so
like the worst pain was sleeping in New
York you deserve this way you can see
it's like wow you do you actually have a
pretty decent-sized scar there yeah Lord
so but like sleeping that night the
first night in New York
my arm was killing me me yes like your
body is rerouting its blood circuit yeah
oh it's frustrating house appraised yeah
I don't recommend I don't recommend ever
killing yourself er I don't need them
well for some people I do if they're
[ __ ] really [ __ ] [ __ ] but you
know for the most part I also agree with
you do not kill yourself no no don't
don't don't
I just thought of a good one Oh what is
it I'm gonna go to the Kentucky Derby
uh-huh I'm gonna walk up to a horse oh I
like where this goes to the back of it
make love punch it square in the [ __ ]
with your dick with my fist row vist and
then either it orange jockey kicks me to
death well I hope it's it because the
jockeys kicking you to death could take
a long time because those guys a little
that's true you know I mean the jockey
would be funnier jockey or a bunch of
jockeys would be funnier also getting
hit by like a clown car and then it
takes like 50 like run over by a car and
then 50 [ __ ] people are just
constantly getting out of this little
car while you're [ __ ] under it I
think yeah I mean what a horse's kick is
it a horse's kick is that strong right
okay
oh yeah horse ok you could by God you to
death
absolutely yeah absolutely I know one of
the biggest dangers is like Old Farmer's
like for peak like dudes farming in
their 80s and like trying to herd cattle
so a surprisingly amount of you know
large amount of people get inter doing
that or die I'm not surprised by that at
all
yeah that's a very hard job
Marvin because you always wind up doing
it into your 60 70s yeah and you're
stubborn you're like oh I've been doing
this my whole life I'm 18 now but I can
still all your tools have like dump tape
around yeah you know your [ __ ] turn
I've had I mean you you grew up in a
rural areas I did yeah so you get how
hard that is you fall I imagine you have
either bailed hay or detasseled corn
empty tassel now you know about the
Tesla of course I grew up in Indiana of
course I do my high school summer job
and it was the worst but you would make
good money yeah for good but for yeah
for you know 15 16 yeah make good money
yeah but it was brutal days for like you
would do it for like a month
yeah and then you were like [ __ ] man you
I cry I'll cry
yeah just cuz will you she'd come home
dirty is absolutely oh you would
whatever you wore details and corny
would just throw it away at the end of
the song yeah buddy and son cuz you
would even want to co sunburn for sure
terrible son I can't believe you did it
okay as well-built hey but you know what
I loved about the Tassili corn is like
the first tee the first job he has a
teenager where like you would always go
there in the back of somebody somebody's
pickup truck absolutely and were you
like it would be back yeah and where you
first learned like you know really like
you learn curse words when you're young
but you learn like sexual terms when
you're like in the back of a pickup
truck going to a crappy job yeah with
some weird creepy guy that wants to suck
your dick it's exactly what it is yeah
Wow
there's like porno mags in the back of
the pickup yeah old man Wilson really is
weird it makes me feel funny it's kind
of like that now you're a big Hayes well
we were talking last night your big
bills han huge huge bills fan we're in
the bill shirt right now and we were
talking about the shady McCoy situation
now that almost seems like an
appropriate nickname for him now okay
is shady do you think Hades as a fan
that he did this that he what what his
girlfriend is claiming is that if
anybody doesn't know what happened the
bills running back
shady McCoy who is one of the better
running backs in the NFL even though
he's probably around 29 or 30 yeah 20
maybe 28 20 but he's at least 29 he
here's where he [ __ ] up and is what
you were saying last night he and his
girlfriend his girlfriend won't leave
his house he has a house in Atlanta that
she won't leave and he keeps trying to
kick her out but he needs to get like
a sheriff to come by and evict her but
the way the laws are so she's like I
ain't even for [ __ ] ain't even nothing
so she's not leaving and then he has
this jewelry that she says was a gift to
her that he says was loaned to them to
wear to events and now he has to give
that back or he has to pay for it so
it's like $80,000 worth of jewelry that
they had loaned to them which happens
very a lot a lot people always do that
for award shows and stuff like that so
they they're like you buy this or just
return it so he asked for it back and
she was like [ __ ] you that's a gift
she's doing everything she can to [ __ ]
him over yeah she's very you know like a
disgruntled ex so he asked for the
specific jewelry back and she says [ __ ]
you n-word I ain't givin [ __ ] back and
then a month later coincidentally she is
a burglar breaks into their house and
only steals exactly what he he was the
burglar was looking for the exact same
jewelry coincidentally beat the [ __ ] out
of her hit her with a gun her faces all
[ __ ] up now we were saying last night
it does look suspicious because of that
fact
like he if he did do that if he did set
her up and he paid this guy to go reseal
all that [ __ ] steal a VCR - that's what
we were saying money I killed some
random [ __ ] steal some like crackers out
of the cabinet whatever I need dis
necklace this necklace and this bracelet
and this watch but also grab the VCR
grab from some [ __ ] silverware or
whatever you know I mean don't only
steal these things because she has a
text message where I'm asking for those
things from you you don't mean that's
why she said she was set up because she
proved she had a text where he's like
hey I need this back this back this back
this back they're asking me for 80 grand
for it or whatever yeah and I want to
return it and she's like [ __ ] you n-word
that's a gift I'm keeping that you ain't
getting [ __ ] you know blah blah blah
she's a pissed-off crazy [ __ ] right the
girl
black right yeah yeah okay so she's
calling him the n-word it's nice yeah
yeah yeah I don't know even if it wasn't
you know you're right she's black enough
to be dating shady McCoy I don't know if
they were married or I know they weren't
okay okay okay it looks really bad I'm
surprised that he's not suspended I'm
shocked well but all it is is like her
word against his word really it's just
her what is they've suspended AAP for
worse or you've heard you know for less
in a way yeah like that was a weird one
what was a weird where they just like
held him out for you yeah because the
little kid had scars not scar both yeah
it's scars I guess now permanent scars
but at least you could tell that he had
been hit with a switch but he wasn't
suspended right he was still he was like
exempt but pay died what was that
situation
I don't recall but I think he was
suspended okay I think I think so
Goodell still does kiddo have the power
now that he did four years ago when he
suspended Adrian Peterson I don't think
you know I think the [ __ ] NFL is
being run by Trump right now I really
think he's got them by the do you see
LeBron said I saw it on CNN this morning
what Trump's trying to ruin sports oh I
agree with that well the thing is is
this like in people can say whatever
they want now I don't think that trumps
beef is the anthem or patriotism and
clearly he doesn't understand what they
are protesting when I say they I mean
the african-american NFL players that
are taking a knee because they are
saying I'm not going to honor a country
that is allowing this police brutality
on my race of people that's really what
it always was it never was anything
about troops of it there's nothing about
[ __ ] America it was nothing about I
don't like the anthem as a song or
whatever you know it was just like hey I
want to bring some awareness to the fact
that at that point in time two kids
under the age of twenty and two adult
men were either choked to death or shot
to death just because they were
can look like somebody or whatever so
they're like hey man this is starting to
be a problem and let's bring some
awareness to it by protesting Trump made
it about this and that and the other
thing but really Trump's boner is always
been the NFL when he became president he
was like I'm gonna find a way to [ __ ]
the NFL up because they wouldn't let me
buy the Buffalo Bills you're in the
[ __ ] 70s and then I tried to sue him
for a monopoly and I won the lawsuit and
it was only a $1 a check for $1 he's
hated the NFL since 1986
since the USFL and before that because
they wouldn't let him his father by the
bills teeb not even in the 70s he wanted
to buy the bills when Ralph Wilson died
like just a few years ago oh it was
between it was the weirdest group of
investors like badly it was it was like
a group of three P was three people
trying to buy the bills Trump Bon Jovi
and called Bon Jovi's always had a boner
for the NFL yeah here's a doozy but they
here's the New Jersey lip syncher
seriously google this it's hilarious
because this story came out like a year
ago but allegedly I Bon Jovi claim
because a lot of Bills fans hated Bon
Jovi and his music was boycotted by
Buffalo stations because people thought
he wanted to move the team to Toronto
okay and then about a year ago I I read
the story about how some a lot of people
think that that was started by that
rumor that hey he wants to move your
team that well that seems like it right
now it really does what do you would do
it it like it I totally seen that
happening fortunately neither of them
got it and the Pegula's did and their
Buffalo natives yeah so the team staying
in there which I don't care I'm not from
Buffalo but you know I'm Bills fans
happy yeah that's a good fan base to
even though and I want money
yeah oh it's a great fan base great fan
base I mean it's literally that and
Niagara Falls are the only things that
are right there
yeah and both of them they don't want to
leave no I don't know how you could get
Niagara Falls to leave but no man you
know yeah my favorite bill of all time
though is Doug Flutie I thought about
wearing many places your favorite yeah
Marc Ellis has a box of Flutie flakes
just like you wanted I'm like might
right Norwood oh really
was that the kicker yeah I was like Tim
Burton is very bad for him did you see
the the four seasons before unbelievable
yeah I almost it's emotional yeah you
watch it you really feel everything he
felt and everything he had to go through
oh when they brought him to the the
parade and they were just cheering for
him happens without you that's that's
really that exact moment is what makes
me always think of them as a great fan
base yeah because that's great they
still look stay don't like if that
happened at Philly I'm not saying
Philly's not a good fan base it's just
more it's an angrier kind of country
your fan base like if that would you
would just get booed outed like you
would never get to you would have to
change your [ __ ] social security
number and go in a witness protection
program yeah it's kind of why I hated
Cubs fans for the longest time it's how
they treated Bartman oh that's a great
another great example of that
I mean we're ganna anybody anybody in
that position where you see a ball
coming right down to your head you're
gonna try to catch it you don't you're
not factoring all of that in no he
wasn't on the radio to second delay he
wasn't even an [ __ ] or anything he
was just a regular guy yeah you know he
was a great fan he loved the Cubs loved
him and he had a lead I'd leave the city
yeah like he pretty much and you can
witness purchase well almost
okay like he had to get as close to like
undercover as you could death threats
just a regular guy a fan of fan of fans
was getting death threats in such hell
too because it happened like right
before Halloween so a bunch of people
dressed up as Bartman for halibut death
threats as his favorite from his
favorite thing ever
yeah like he was a die-hard Cubs fan and
loved the cups so much so that he had
bought playoff tickets
he loved it so much that he went to a
playoff game while listening to the game
info on a Walkman well they're like he's
that nerd yeah that's it now that thing
that you love the most
it's almost like if like pornography
turned its back to Sam Tripoli you know
I mean like a pot turned its back to Ari
Shaffir and every stone in the world was
like [ __ ] you bro don't ever [ __ ]
smoke pot again or he's like you know
name his favorite thing was the Cubs and
everything in the world was like not
only can you not like the Cubs you are
the cancer to the Cubs but the way the
fans treated him let's tear and Moises
Alou overreacted like that yeah there's
no guarantee I'll who catches that ball
yes he's a good father but not at all
empires not even called fan interference
right you know Lou just loses his [ __ ]
yeah he overplayed are like oh I could
have caught that and if Alex Gonzalez
makes the routine ground ball play next
play Aaron thank you for remembering
that because so many people don't
Aaron's not a very big baseball fan he's
a much more of a soccer guy don't care
for it he's a soccer are you really a
soccer fan no I love baseball okay okay
he loves how much baseball we talk on
the show are you only a baseball fan
pretty much yeah Wow you're old school
who's your team
Cardinals he's a big guy see I like the
Cardinals cuz the coast hey wow I've
always loved the Cardinals good I mean
I'm a White Sox fan
so I does that make you a cup hater no
no but I but I remember when I was in
college and the Sox won the series
against the Astros a bunch my Cubs fans
because you know I went to the
University of Iowa a lot of Chicago
people yeah absolutely Chicago
absolutely one of them went to the the
White Sox parade Oh
Cubs yeah well they trust me I was at
the Cubs parade there were a lot of
whites on your hands at that okay that's
cool that's just celebrating the city
yeah yeah that's a reason to party and
drink during the day and take the day
off work in the coves parade have like
two million people is the big library oh
my god five and a half million and
it was top ten biggest public gatherings
ever and seven of the ten are all like
pilgrimages to [ __ ] Mecca yeah and
like create like the end of World War
two like crazy [ __ ] like that
that's insane and there might have been
one other sports one or that may have
been the only sport one it was nuts
I mean per five and a half million
[ __ ] people dude I love but I love
October baseball and I love it for all
the reasons because I that I hate summer
baseball it's slow its dramatic yeah
that was the best World Series I've ever
seen and that's yeah that was amazing in
the last decade I mean when you go there
and spoiled they're down in the series
and then it finally goes to seven and
sevens on the road and it goes to extra
innings then there's a rain delay during
extra innings I mean it's too much man
it's unbelievable yes you could
definitely the best game seven yeah
we've ever seen sure
I still think Arizona New York 2001 was
my favorite really of all time did they
go seven yeah okay yeah extras a lot of
people were rooting for New York in that
series too and yeah just because of 9/11
which Boston winning was pretty excited
that was a good series too but that was
almost it was no yeah yes yes yes what
was stole all the thunder of that I
didn't kind of just rolled into the
series with that but that was a Haiti
went awesome
yeah I was so like we can [ __ ] take
the Yankees but that pitching staff
Pedro Schilling I'm like we can't yeah
but and we had a hundred five wins that
year and still Wow wet bass Sox like we
weren't even there
that's that sucks wait now the Cardinals
Rangers World Series right yeah 2011 did
that go seven
yes but seven was very uneventful six
was the big one I love that series
though yeah I watched I remember
watching almost every game and and that
was when I really realized like God dang
what courts do you play growing up I
mean oh yeah I was I was a I played a
lot of basketball playing you know
different leagues ain't you whatever
those are
my best for baseball it was baseball is
my favorite sport to play but now you
can only play it a few months a year I
was always jealous of kids that grew up
in Florida California got that
year-round baseball yeah and then I got
it those are called major league
baseball players no no no like seriously
Iowa doesn't have many many yeah in Iowa
and Indiana in the Midwest you could
play baseball for 90 days out of the
year yeah unless you're playing like
indoor [ __ ] yeah but like the actual
outdoor nine people you know in the feet
you know there's a hundred days where
you can play baseball yeah and that's it
yeah that's it I was a wrestling stay
and I never wrestled but you know Dan
Gable no okay
he's he's the best amateur wrestler ever
he it was in the Munich Olympics I
believe they nobody scored a point on
him oh wow which is like winning
Wimbledon just which serves I think he
was on he went to wear your high school
ISM no he's he's from I know he's from
Waterloo Iowa Nebraska is just like dude
- just don't how to wrestle they just
want to [ __ ] pin you to the ground
that's it [ __ ] that's why I don't
have a flower ear I don't fight anybody
who's like shorter than five five in
like Boni yeah because those people they
got leverage yeah like because that's
basketball players we'd always fight the
wrestlers you know is just kind of just
like Crips and bloods sure Iowa and we'd
always fight him before like practices
sometimes and we go the wrestling room
where they practiced and the wrestlers
always practiced by the boiler room like
they were in her intense they had no
circulation in the in that in that room
it's just a room full of mat so it's fun
to fight in but they always kicked our
asses because we're tall and they're
short and you know they they you know
they got muscles and like you said the
cauliflower here they don't even fine
Aaron said it best era he was talking
about um he's the air needs to be a
bounce or a door guy and he's like I
always used to look for people that they
had weapons you know back in the day you
would look for people with weapons and
it goes and now you just look at a
cauliflower here yeah be there I would
look at people's eyes and hands to
determine whether or not
threat yeah and now it's cauliflower
here isin hands how do you tell what the
eyes and hands eyes you can tell whether
they have a what kind of personality
they got if they're gonna be an [ __ ]
hands always just like calluses no just
if they had a weapon oh yeah yeah yeah I
always looked hours now with brazilian
Brazilian jiu-jitsu taking over the
world it's like you know everyone's a
weapon I love making those ears you know
oh yeah yeah when I watch the UFC fight
if I always if I always think the guy
with the most cauliflower is gonna win
billions like puffy years like oh he's
gonna kick his ass there's this girl I
met that I kind of like a little bit of
a crush on and I met her at the store
that so then I was following on
Instagram
and she is like maybe a year in to
Brazilian jiu-jitsu yeah and she posts a
lot of videos and she's really into it
he's not that good at it yeah but
chillin like I've done that for a year
but she's really really into it and she
posts all these videos of her like
learning and kind of coming up in BJJ
and I'm like that is so [ __ ] huh you
know why cuz that's a woman that can
take a punch
she's training to how to get choked out
professionally and take a punch what's
hotter than that bro ya know man I love
it I really do think it's hot like a
chick training in BJJ to me it was hot
and I didn't see that coming but when I
was looking at her videos I was like god
damn I didn't this is actually helping
her case you know I don't know what I
find so hard about it I'll tell you what
I mean let me tell you this it's nice
yeah I like women they can fight back I
mean not good enough you didn't mean
like don't I wouldn't want to be like
abused you know like a challenge I hurt
about Juliet I like a challenge it good
and also like a bike like if you were to
smack a [ __ ] up let's just say back in
the old days of like a couple weeks ago
everyone's like oh you can't hit a woman
blah blah blah
now clearly she's paying people to hit
her yeah I'll do it for free
and just kind of like helper I think
every guy kind of wants around around
see I think to at least see yeah I grew
up on American Gladiators so I'm kind of
turned on by women that look like
[ __ ] Oh rabbit aren't you no so is
everybody else on this show apparently
by the way I don't know where re is but
I believe Edinboro go see if you guys
are around you're listening this today
tonight is comedy chaos at the Comedy
Store the first shows sold out so you
can't even get into it so don't even try
think the second one is - is it really
yeah well then [ __ ] off guys you [ __ ]
up two opportunities see Rogen and shall
band Bobby Lee and every single person
at the Comedy Store that ever lived Theo
Theo everybody's that tripolis show
tonight so but it's every other week so
check out comedy chaos next week I will
be at the dojo at Sycamore tavern yeah
Friday and 8:00 o'clock send an tow and
I are doing this kind of like improv
show which should be very fun so please
come check that out I'll be at the store
this week I'll be at the Chum Bucket all
of Shark Week and I will be at the 11
fingers in teaching my road to glory
hole seminar so come check that out
that's tonight at 2:00 a.m. what do you
got you got any dates you got anything
you want to plug or easin Edinboro so if
you guys are there check that out he'll
be there for pretty much until Christmas
and go to Sam Tripoli live.com and you
can see where trips is gonna be Tripoli
will be back next week by the way how
many of those gigs you just you just
listed on for real
the chumbucket that's real nope most
usually just the first one okay well you
know what I might say I live three
blocks away from the dojo and I love
that room that's it's really a fun fun
and the one sandy and I are doing I
guess it's like um there's like a panel
of people and there's only three guests
but all of its almost like a whose line
is it anyway kind of a thing I guess
okay what time is it I think it's at
8:00 okay
I might stop - yeah I I love that rooms
over do you work Friday
Trevor's great yeah he's also from
Chicago
oh I know he's a Sox fan too yeah I saw
the me he told me okay and yeah I filmed
actually I like filming in that room
because it's it's like a New York Club
it is a New York club yeah it it that
place is gonna take off I agree
okay dates Wednesday names night so it
was a great show explain to everybody
what that what regulars go up on the LR
everybody that got their name on the
wall is all it's pretty much half the
lineup of the o.r yeah and then I'm in
Chicago in two weeks
16th through 18th dope-ass comedy show
that that Friday night or I'm sorry that
Thursday night and I apologize um
Saturday will be at the Laugh Factory
that's have you done that let factory
know it's great huge it's huge isn't it
twice the size of the la work I think
they're whole I think it was 400 yeah
one time I was one time I was there
because I day was giving guest spots
whenever I go home and I was there and
before I would checked out the showroom
Brian the guy that run runs it there he
goes hey man I'm sorry man we don't have
too many [ __ ] people I'm like yeah no
worries dude thanks for the guest spot
you know yeah I mean when you hear that
in LA that means it's [ __ ] 60 people
in there yeah there's like 220 people in
there and it was like half full and he
was like I'm so sorry I'm like I walked
in expecting like 50 yeah and it was
like the whole bottom was totally full
but just the top wasn't and I'm like
dude this is crazy cool what do you mean
he's sorry is 200 plus people here
it's a beautiful club part of me wishes
I'd known the stand-up scene in Chicago
because I was just associated with
improv in second city well it's only
been really great stand-up wise for like
the last like 10 years it was always
just second city and and improv and that
for a long time and they had like two or
three clubs yeah now there's no it's
booming stand applause yeah yeah it's
still great improv but it's booming its
booming like they have like was it
called comedy bar is that a new place
okay it's about four years old okay
because when I started over by the river
but yeah
okay when I started all they really knew
was a knees yeah yeah there's 3z knees
in the area but only but the main ones
downtown and yeah and they they're used
to being improv and it closed and then
but now there's a bunch of [ __ ] yeah but
you look at some of the guys that came
out of there to Canaan and Hannibal and
yeah Camille said yep you know and TJ
right yeah I mean there's a lot people
to chemo so I I wish I'd known azar so
funny man oh he's a man Braunger another
one yeah
John Huck yeah little arias yeah I
forgot that hooky and I will open my
cruiser together
really how can a tonight thank God
Canaan and Bronner and I used to drink
all the time
Canaan drinks no way okay I imagine that
yeah me and Canaan have had a couple
beers together
but we were all open mic returns like
one person would drive and then everyone
else would just we would just get
schnockered just hit every open mic that
we could back in like the mid nineties
are you doing like the Rosemount zany's
oh of course
okay how far is Rosemont from my Chicago
like if you're in a car maybe without
traffic 40 okay you know it's like it's
like like going to like an Angels game
yeah from Hollywood yeah I mean I was
like Disney like Disney ish yeah and
okay I love that City suburb suburb what
rosewater know Chicago the first time I
ever went there is it was a kid it's a
bass we're visiting Northwestern with my
brother and your brother go to north
while he didn't want to I on the end but
I'll never feel it and the whole city's
wonderful yeah it really is my favorite
it's my favorite Enya in America you go
there like during Taste of Chicago oh
absolutely
oh yeah court McGowan flipping us off
you know let me give a thumbs up
oh god your middle finger tell them to
come in
here's a great thing you should do yeah
if I know you love music you got a lot
of events if you guys ever
need tickets to anything I have a great
idea what you should do
download the app SeatGeek use that on
your phone and here's what's great about
see geek I just went to a concert
recently I went to go see we were
promised jetpacks the ban you probably a
lot of people have never heard of guess
you heard him see geek no problem
someone's like hey that this bands gonna
be in town
I don't like ah Betsy geek as it sure as
[ __ ] bang
now I've already used my code several
times so I don't get the discount that
you guys will get but if you put in the
code promo code punch-drunk that's the
promo code punch-drunk you get 20 bucks
off the first ticket you buy to anything
I'm gonna go to an Angels game you want
to go to a
zany's in Chicago if you happen to me in
Chicago you want to go to the Laugh
Factory and see my good friend new the
newest paid regular Lucas hurl at Zanies
and/or the Laugh Factory in Chicago put
in the promo code punch lucky you
probably can see him for free
because you get 20 bucks off of it and
that's probably about what that ticket
costs so wherever you are whatever
you're doing whatever you're looking to
do all the tickets prices are guaranteed
you're not gonna get shifted or shout
[ __ ] over
no one's gonna rip you off and wherever
you are like when we were in New York
and I was just like what's going on you
know what I don't say sucks I love doing
the festival we were doing but I was
sitting in the green room and I
literally was using SeatGeek to just see
well I'm in Brooklyn what's going on
what's around what I meant you know is
there a [ __ ] hockey game going on
right now is there a bet you know
baseball game I wanted to see like what
who's in town what concert and then
while I was in Brooklyn you know who is
it the Barclays Center in Brooklyn or no
it was Madison Square Garden they were
in the city it's 40 minutes away one
night only [ __ ] Radiohead oh yeah and
I was like oh dude how cool would it
have been to go see Radiohead on a
[ __ ] Saturday night [ __ ] Madison
Square Garden but I was doing the
festival so I couldn't yeah
but I was like holy [ __ ] I would have
even known that one of my all-time
favorite bands was in the
same city i was at at the same time i
was there if it wasn't for my good
friends at c-- geek so highly recommend
you getting nap and I highly recommend
you using the code punch-drunk the first
time you buy tickets on there because
you will buy tickets they're all
guaranteed and you need tickets they got
them so thank you to our good friends at
C geek
suck it did you go to a lot of concerts
you do your um not as much anymore I
used to I went to Coachella one year a
couple years ago with piddle cone I
think that's the way to do it like don't
go to any concerts all year and then go
to like a festival once a year and like
get like I bunny bands out of the way
I've been loving comedy festivals lately
I've done a couple recently oh god I
can't I'm going to skank fest next year
sounds like oh my god it was so fun
there's like 90% dude well the all
things comedy festival and by the way
guys I'm willing to bet you might even
be able to find tickets for that on see
cake all things comedy festival is the
October 25th 22 the 28th in Phoenix if
you guys are fans of punch-drunk or 92 7
2 pot or anything that's going on at
here at all things comedy I really
recommend you guys going to the outings
comedy festival it was so much fun
Aaron it was a blast a [ __ ] right so
much so much fun this year is guaranteed
to be more fun than last year I remember
okay so there's two hotels that we're
all in two hotels I don't know if this
would be the same but this how it was
last year and then there's a comedy club
and then there's the pop-up studio where
everybody was doing podcasts all day now
but during the day there would be these
events of like a pool party at one of
the you know pools of the hotel whenever
so and then Yousef was staying at that
hotel I was staying at the one across
the street so I go hey man are you going
to the pool party thing that's in your
hotel today he goes yeah I'll be there
so we I go there and I'm right when I
walk in I'm early only people I see is
Eric from the store and he's standing
there by the bar having a drink and it's
like if you have your lanyard thing it
was like free
boos I think - yeah so I go over there
grab a cocktail my damn self and now see
the only person is just laying on the
Sun is Nick Youssef by the pool so I
walk over to him and I go hey how's it
going he goes just checking out the view
know when he says that I think it's
gonna be a hot chick right so I lay on
the thing turn around on a look at the
pool one person is in the pool Doug
Stanhope in a full suit he had a yellow
sport coat a necktie a shirt and he's
again water up to his [ __ ] waist
you know things drink no milk in a
cigarette and he's got a goddamn
cocktail but he's in the pool in a suit
drinking and it's like one o'clock an
afternoon like this it's gonna be a fun
party like an hour long drive for him
that's it this is how this starts this
is gonna be [ __ ] awesome and it was
super fun so yeah there's podcasts all
day and then every night it's a [ __ ]
15 to 2 shows 10 people per show and
it's just like you know Kreischer then
stanhope than me then triple e then re
then [ __ ] bill burr then [ __ ] the
line-up is like insane and everyone just
does 12 and then there's two shows and
then you go to bed and you wake up and
you go to a bunch of parties all day and
then you do a couple of podcasts and
then do you do another set it's awesome
as [ __ ] that's a nice house stand-up
shows like that should always be
whatever level you're at like I love
when people do like 12 minutes I love
like I love Burke but you know and I'd
love to see him do an hour I've seen him
do two hours in person but like he's
seen ago I came have to convince 12
minutes oh and the same thing with Rogan
- like you know brother don't do
back-to-back 15 minutes or whatever then
do like he'll do 4 spot tonight at those
and he's hilarious
don't get me wrong but to watch Rogan do
the exact same he gets a light of 10 and
then wrap it up with - yeah that
everybody else is doing at a festival
like that is fun yeah like as a stand-up
comedian I like to see I'd rather see
like six different guys then like two
dudes
and yeah one guy do five and then one
guy just do an hour fifty yeah yeah yeah
I totally agree with that and that's why
the disgust holes are so fun because you
get there's such an array of everything
you know that you're not just like hey
this is uh you know I'm watching Bill
burr all weekend were you like wow I got
turned onto like nine different comics
yeah I didn't really know I knew his
stand-up
I knew his special I knew him from the
games reality second Americans got
whoever what about Phillipe Esparza I
didn't know him too - well we didn't we
knew of each other we'd say hi but we
net but that whole weekend me and him
hung out like quite a bit at the last
one and kind of became buddies and then
we came back to LA and about a month
went by we hadn't talked to each other
but I remember like hey it's summer camp
he and I got along really good and then
I walked in here and he was we're good
so it felt like he was recording in here
and he goes a fool I'll be digging if I
you may you were so funny when we were
meeting so I'm like cool okay because I
have the same crush on you yeah but had
I not gone to that I wouldn't have
probably sought out his comedy or
whatever I knew he was if we were on the
same show up maybe we would have watched
him but you know we hung out and smoke
pot and made it to the laughs and talked
about our families and all that kind of
[ __ ] you know that's what's so fun about
these festivals and you know with your
friends in different cities is the best
and like when you can do it with 15 of
your friends or 30 of them that you
started a goddamn Network with here you
know I mean it's almost like a it's
almost like our corporate Christmas
party it just happens to be in October
yeah you know what it feels like and an
errand was getting so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude this guy Aaron how much was it did
you get I mean oh I'll say all of it
well because your wife was not yet there
your wife was gone right she was not was
not there yeah but dude you got you this
guy couldn't keep it in his pants
I mean I had a suite I had to use it all
I took what do you one time Aaron and I
are coming back from like the show or
something I think he was relatively
sobered by I definitely was not and so
we walk in the hotel but like all the
way down the way
I could see there's like some people in
the hotel like 2:00 3:00 in the morning
and there was like this like like big
pillar right here as we're walking this
way
and I'm like come in room number you in
and Aaron's like ah there is no way I'm
gonna tell you what room number I'm in
do you think I'm stupid to tell you my
room number oh my god that's fine man
you don't have to [ __ ] trust me I get
it I get it
but what floor you on though because I'm
trying to [ __ ] maybe we're on the
same floor I don't know he goes I'm on
the seventh floor and then I yell right
when he says he's on the seventh floor I
yell all the way down the hall hey my
name is Erin I live on the seventh floor
you dumb [ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ]
and then I deck around that pillar so
then when everybody turned and look it
was just him standing there I'm one of
the yellows room numbers so bad he's
like well I got to tell you my room
number don't look stupid but you knew it
no I didn't know it I wish I did do you
remember each it won't tell me he's yeah
he's still here that was on the 14th
floor so ok whatever for such a secret
the 13th floor you mean yeah yeah yeah
isn't that weird they know hotels have
13th floors yeah or a lot of 14th is the
13th a lot don't ya right
that's so weird like it's silly I mean
some people like 13s are lucky number
two though innit
yeah Dan Marino I mean what if you're
bored on the 13th you're just like I
guess I'm I am a D are you really really
the 13th of what October no way you're
all sorts of rebel a yeah I'm the 16th
but not like that's the worst month to
have the 13th into is October the
Halloween month yeah dude you must be I
turned 13 on Friday the 13th Wow Wow no
wonder you're always so mad at
everything
no wonder you beat your up do you know
he beats his wife well that's what she
tells me but I think she's just doing
that for sympathy and for some of the
sex games she likes to play with me but
how how how is everything going with the
wife update us on your pregnancy
attempts
great you still giving her the
spray-down yep now you're leaving it in
for that right in yeah see that's the
thing that's our County man you can't
get her pregnant coming all over stomach
or your stomach or is she in the are you
having sex with her she care and we got
to talk after the show I got a I'm gonna
have to help this guy trying to have a
baby but he's doing everything all wrong
I mean he has a dog now so he's good you
know that baby buy stuff that's what
they call that in a baby practice are
you do you care about preseason football
no I just don't want anybody getting
hurt that's a thing that's what I was
saying that last night because a
preseason is right around the corner
next week preseason starts up and if you
hurt crazy if you're crazy person let's
see let's say you're crazy I'm crazy
you're a gambler yeah no I mean how much
card player I have I don't
our good friend cones are good friends
of bet DSi bet DSi comm use the code
punch 25 that'll get you 25 three bucks
to gamble with I highly recommend
parlays because if you're gonna get 25
free bucks even if you're not a gambler
it's it's a $25 pull of the wheel you
know I mean so why not just parlay it
into like bet on four baseball games and
try it like because if you win you get
like three four hundred bucks on a
parlay yeah
if you lose I mean who wants you know
you could put it on one fight and win 19
bucks and then keep it rolling but I say
get crazy with a parlay I do not
recommend pre-season bets oh dude I was
in Vegas a few years ago and I it was
10:00 a.m. I started betting on spring
training baseball it was great see
that's what it's like if you actually
that being said why not why not why not
I I recommend taking the under on every
preseason football game you want to bet
on because they're the offense isn't
clicking it a lot of these people that
are playing aren't that your marquee
guys you're not almost now the others
are gonna be set low but I would take
the under because pre
season football is not 35 to 28 it's not
it's usually like 13 to 3 yeah the
problem to me is if you gamble on
preseason football you have to watch it
yeah that's true that's what I hate
watching preseason football hard walk I
can't do it my main thing with preseason
football is just like oh don't get hurt
like I don't want to see an Julio Jones
do [ __ ] in the preseason I don't want to
see Matt Ryan get touched I don't want
to see him sneeze
you know I mean that's why I hate about
shady McCoy though is that he he's one
of those players that he's slow to get
up after so many plays that you know you
watch a Bills game and your heart will
skip a beat three or four times because
he's just he's slow to get up he limps
and then two plays later he's fine it's
like I don't know I don't want to say
he's a full you know don't act hurt me
probably has heard but can't damn it's
scary it's scary as hell and especially
in the preseason there's nothing worse
than an injury in a preseason that is
meaningless oh yeah like you're like
that guy shouldn't have even been in
there I never get like when people
Terry sales and practice and stuff and
they always say was a routine cut he was
making at it but that is just part of
the game I mean that's a part of the
game aren't some athletes so athletic
that like they're bound to pull muscles
like Jordan Reed you know the tight end
for the rest that guy is the concussion
King he's a great fantasy tight end but
when he plays a full season I don't
think Jordan Reed will play two more
years and he's in the prime of his
career but I think he's two concussions
away from someone going dude when you're
39 you're going to be 65 in the head you
know I mean when you're 45 you're going
to be an 80 year old man upstairs you
know some people just keep getting
dinged in the head I don't think he'll
play more than 12 games in the seasons
or 10 games last time you did oh yeah I
can't either
he's barely a hundred and healthy right
now I don't say that
they do always say that they do it but
not really about him but he is
apparently in hundreds and healthy but
he is one and you know
concussions are it's a progressive thing
so once you've had to you know like
people like Muhammad Ali at the end of
his career you could snap your fingers
in front of him and give him a
concussion because he's had so many that
it's just it becomes your default of you
know it's easier and easier and easier
and easier to get one you know you put
on a baseball hat and get a concussion
yeah some of those guys you know I mean
brushing your teeth you [ __ ] get a
concussion so and Jordan Reed is closely
becoming that yeah Gronk has had a
surprisingly large amount of concussions
as well he just was more like just leg
injuries just he's got quite a few
concussions and he's been kept out of
games for concussions and practices as
well but he just seems like the kind of
guy that's like of course my mom gets
concussions like the whole Gronk family
good I think he was born with a
concussion yeah he just seems like that
kind of like I was gonna ask how you can
tell exactly yeah yeah like Jordan Reed
doesn't seem like that but yeah like
Gronk seems oddly off if he's not
concussed
yeah like he's like he seems like you're
like oh [ __ ] what about this did you
guys see I don't know if I'm if I find
this endearing or I'm sick of it I don't
know endearing or sick of it that's the
new segment all this LeBron James
playing basketball with these eighth
graders and coaching his son who's in
eighth grade and do you see when he's
doing layup drills with the kid to flip
them on tired not fluently yeah that was
the day before okay and then the next
day he's just doing like layup drills
with all these eighth graders and it was
so funny because all these memes were
happening where it's like AAU and all
this but they're like there's no way
this guy's in eighth grade you know
there's always like the 14 year old 8th
grader that could dunk and you're like
dude you should be a JUnit sophomore in
high school I should not be ISO it's
LeBron dunking and all these different
things with all these kids but his son
just dunked the other day for the first
time
honey I believe is his name yeah which i
think is a great name probably into the
paper towels
ya know be ro and then why not no W yeah
but uh so his son Doug for the first
time at a game on camera but 8th grade
13 this guy's [ __ ] just hammering down
dunks the blogs did that's about the age
that you know right young when people
start fun at least start dunking yep and
you're like God that kid he can dunk I
remember that when I was in yes seventh
grade there was this dude they could
dunk Craig Craig read dunked when we
were 12 and we're about the same height
but he but he had a little bit more
athleticism than I did yeah he actually
played for Wisconsin when to play
basketball for Wisconsin that's what I
hated about basketball is it's the one
sport where athleticism really make is
my town Oskaloosa we played this town
called Pella there like 20 minutes away
uh-huh
and you know Kyle Korver yes of course
yeah his that's where he's from and all
him and his brothers and all you know
they're all named after Kay's yeah the K
for his name and his little brother was
Clayton and it's it's a Dutch town and
so everybody was like five inches taller
than than us yeah
and so like we always got our asses
kicked I remember I bet a girlfriends my
girlfriend at the time we were getting
on the bus to go play pehle and I'm like
we're gonna lose she's like you're not
gonna lose me I'll bet you five bucks
and like I bet against my own team Pete
Rose style ah that's nice and yeah like
Clayton Korver like you know his brother
played in the pros and he schooled me he
killed me he was like squirting all over
me man I was terrible I used to go see
we should go watch Glenn Robinson oh
yeah
he's from Indiana his son is playing now
too right he was a missed person - he
went to Denny what - produce yeah and
when I went to Ball State and we went
pretty good played ball state we went
there and I was like watching Glenn
Robinson
he scored like 900 points in that game
but in high school he was unbelievable
mr. basketball in Indiana oh yeah
pick overall first pick overall I think
it yep by Milwaukee yeah and he was
notorious for saying he wouldn't a
hundred million dollar contract and the
owner for the Bucks scoffed at that and
said I only paid thirty five million for
the team when I bought it I bought the
Milwaukee Bucks for thirty five million
dollars that's cool right
nineteen-year-old droughts his 19 year
old and he wants a hundred million
dollars it's like mmm
sorry Charlie you're not gonna get it
but dude he talked about a god it was
just everything was just a monster dunk
everything was a monster dunk but he
didn't have a Hall of Fame career
absolutely not
Hall think what happened was it did get
a Hall of Fame talent the ego I think so
and I think he just kind of like I don't
know I think he was kind of like a poor
man's Shawn Kemp
Brody you got it so Brody's coming up
next guys uh so sorry about the short
episode thank you and congratulations
thank you so proud of you I've known you
your entire term of being there and and
I'm so proud of you for getting your
name on the wall it was such fun hanging
out with all of you guys guys come check
me out at the dojo this week come check
you out Wednesday at the Comedy Store
yeah tomorrow for your big names night
show and if you're in Chicago the 16th
through 18th please hit me up and I'll
get you in yep and hit our friends up at
SeatGeek use' cut punch-drunk and hit
our friends up a bet dsi if you want to
make any bets proceedings around the
corner take the others and use the could
punch 25 and that's just free money to
gamble with [ __ ] faces Sam's back next
week his cooldowns over and a good
friend Ryan Hills having surgery today
so I hope that goes good he's probably
listening to this in about an hour guys
consider it sucked whoooaaa thanks